all right welcome everybody so we have a
different venue for the class today
because there is a tournament at the
Chess Club so but next week we'll be
back there and I'll be doing the
lectures for the next few weeks as well
[Music]
so if you have the time Tuesdays and
Thursdays we have adult lectures and
Sunday we have a puzzle lecture Sunday 5
o'clock so so today I want to show you
this game I played in a North American
Open tournament in Las Vegas and around
6:00 and I'm playing international
master Adam hunt from England so I'm
playing with white pieces so d4 Knight
f6 c4 g6 so we don't know that which
opening is going to be yet it could be
groom felt or Kings Indian so he played
the groom felt and which move makes you
the Kings Indian Bishop g7 Bishop to g7
we'll make it Kings Indian defense so he
played groom groom thought I have to
tell you it's one of the toughest ones
you know to deal with to handle it
because it's always some contra player
always some idea so that's why it's very
difficult to get advantage so I have
many different lines that I play so I
choose the Bishop g5 line this time I
like this line I played it a couple of
times before had some good results with
it so the point of the move is to take
on f6 of course and damage the pawn
structure Knight e4 is one of the main
moves the I would say the very main well
there is Lately Bishop g7 is another
move that people play but usually this
is the main move so now
the threat is to capture the bishop and
[ __ ] page four is the most popular move
but there is also another very
interesting move I actually played once
Knight takes e4 was played in a game
Marazzi which against Carlsen very high
profile game that's a very rare idea
take and Queen d2 okay
developing the Queen and basically at
some point white wants to even play long
castle here so if you go Bishop g7 this
is how costs and game developed it was
something like this
a5 d5 and then white place usually 93 92
93 putting pressure here Bishop e2 and
just castle that's kind of the idea
so c5 d5
so if you want something really rare so
this is this Knight takes e4 idea with
Queen d2 could be something I played a
game against Kaden trough in this lion
so it was interesting game so I play
wish page for the main line so he takes
takes and he takes the pawn so here you
have two options basically one is a tree
that I played and what would be the
second logical option here for white
mm-hmm it would be Queen a4 check just
capture the pawn on c4 okay that would
be the other option although Queen a for
Quincy for you moving the Queen so many
times you know that's not that's not
particularly that great okay
so Bishop e6 look a b-1
or okb-1 the idea is just to develop the
rook and put pressure on B 7 B 6 plate
Knight f3 developing my idea to regain
this pawn at some point if I can and
claim that I have advantage because of
the strong center and an active Bishop
on h4 plays Bishop g7 but it's not so
easy to get the pawn back block is just
trying to sort of hang on Bishop e2
developing the bishop castles
castles
see 6 now if he has the time he was to
play b5 and protect so he wants to play
b5 and protect the the pawn on c4
so I played efore I'm not too worried
about gaining the pawn back immediately
I just want to get the control of the
center and at some point maybe we won't
go for a aggressive attack 95f for ideas
if I played this move right away here he
plays the Bishop d5 if you play e4 that
runs into h6 attacking the knight if you
retreat then he wins the pawn on e4 and
if you capture he takes takes pawn takes
and block strengthens his pawn structure
and he is actually up upon two so next
one we will play knight c6 takes
so that's why I want to play the movie
for first because now Knight g5 for
example is very strong
we'll be hitting the bishop bishop moves
back takes on c4 but I knew he's gonna
play this and protect the pond so right
now I'm basically down upon I do have
the control of the center so any force I
could have but I don't know if it
changes much let's say if it's a six
he's still gonna play the movie five and
I don't know if it did this change is so
much 9555 before age six
it's same pretty much same concept here
okay white maybe has some compensation
here I can play h4 h5 quickly you know
some compensation yeah
so
I paid for b5 Quincy won so why did I
play this move
Quincy won and what am I trying to do
with this move
what do you think I would like to go
where to a3 a3 and put pressure on e7 so
this is gonna be an idea that I want to
do at some point okay
Queen goes to a tree and put it pressure
Bishop chief or played by my opponent
he's trying to play e5 okay and now what
to do
what should I do here
huh
I should play five right away or maybe
because you play a five you allowing
Bishop f5 attacks you know so excellent
always want to get a pair of the bishops
having the pair of the bishop is
considered to be an advantage so here he
is gonna give up the bishop I take and
the good thing is you cannot play e5
here because my bishop is pinning so I
do have a I think a pretty good
compensation here for the sacrificed
pawn okay I have an active Bishop on h4
active Bishop on f3 my pieces are pretty
active here yeah so it's a it's a very
good compensation Queen c7 he plays
developing his Queen and now threatening
to play which move e5 now what should I
do
absolutely I play d5 I block his Bishop
prevent the move e5 and the most
important thing I opened the diagonal
for my Bishop it's a multi multi-purpose
move right so very importantly five now
he plays a six he's trying to hang out
to the pawn and at some point I was also
taking threatening to take this idea so
this was another consideration so let's
I played a six now
so a four I didn't play a four because
let's say he plays a 6 right so you take
take take correct
he takes 96
well if you take quintics I don't think
I have much of an advantage
okay
so eh yeah this is important I thought
the c6 was interesting yeah I want to
make sure I stop him from playing e6 and
for a moment he cannot develop his night
either so I think it's a it's a very
good move
b6 so takes
not rookie why I don't want to allow him
look f3 sacrifice at some point he might
throw this thing because it will really
destroy my - bishop advantage and damage
the structure so I wasn't so sure so the
point here is if let's say I go here
takes takes I don't know I feel like he
might get some you know 97 and he might
have a compensation okay no I
it's an idea but even 97 I I kind of
don't want to hear my king position
weakened so that's why I started with
Queenie tree okay I'm not I'm not saying
look after is just but it is very
interesting now I'm down to puns this if
I have anyway and he basically wants to
if I capture he might even go Queenie
five
so what do you think I played here
absolutely d5 yes absolutely d5 yes
absolutely if he takes a hair bishop d5
check
now it goes King h8
Brook fd1 which piece is not developed
here Rokon fd1 right so whenever you
have undeveloped piece you want to bring
that piece into the game as well
he takes rook takes I'm still down to
pawns
we're playing for pure compensation here
with two bishops a leading development
Queen a seven exchanging the Queen's
he's two pounds ahead he feels you know
safe and comfortable about it so let's
think here because this is the important
moment here okay let's think here let's
think here this is the important moment
okay this is the I would say it's a
critical moment in this game who said
Roxy five are they 97
22
kind of worried about this
tis this probably not okay this is
unclear yeah
okay
what about this idea Brooke fd1 now
controlling the file completely so the
knight can never go to d7 and if he goes
to knight c6 I always have rook c5 idea
to put pressure
Queen takes Queen as a possibility he
played 96 right away for Queen takes
Queen Ashish I take probably this was
his best move we look at my notes yeah
Queen takes Queen let's see if Queen
takes Queen I take with the pawn
yeah something like this he could have
played sure
yeah I have [ __ ] dat looks quite
unpleasant for him threatening to
capture capture the other group comes to
d8
kingi it guys what about we should be 5
check yeah ok but that's maybe you
survived but it's not ok
he took he went here 96 developing queen
c5 rook c5 is a possibility as well
something was kind of Lussier Shino so
think about this
look here ah I think something like this
out of nowhere attacking this this and
this
so
that's why I played Queen c5 so I don't
have to worry about that so he plays
through kc8 he couldn't take the Queen
because I take with the rook and then
I'm attacking so he had to go here takes
takes Bishop e7 okay we're only down one
pawn now that's done only one pawn now
he goes here
Bishop c5 hitting the pot Knight again
so this game actually demonstrates to
you how to use the pair of the bishops
to your advantage
okay so decide you can give up a pawn
usually no problem sometimes even two
pawns and you have a compensation it
wasn't like I was clearly better but I
always had a compensation like it was a
little bit easier for me to play the
game I always had some ideas that I was
threatening I was trying to do and he
had to decide on okay so he goes here
Bishop c5 sorry he played here and now
activate your bishops always look for
ways to activate your bishop excellent
hearing their rock
there should be six I don't know D he
just goes rook F seven or something need
to create a threat she just attacked him
moves away now much is happening yeah
Bishop d7 they should be seven I think
he just moves the rock now maybe he
plays yeah rook d7 rook d7 forces things
now if he takes I think I'm winning
I think Bishop takes remove the wig so
here boom attack this guy takes
and I go here okay
so he that's why I went here he went
back here now a rock t6
so you understand what happened I went
here he went here I dropped two d6
that's very important because that keeps
an attack on this guy so if you move the
rook I take the knight and if he goes
here what's the move there you go
there you go now we're winning the game
we're winning material and we're winning
the game all right
so that's something for you to remember
using the bishops so he's he decided to
give up the the pawn here he was in time
trouble already so he basically it's
losing the knight on c6 is dominated by
the dark square bishop who is covering
up all the squares and he cannot do
anything like this either because I just
take the knight and it takes the rook I
take back okay so he played efore and
now
captured the rook captured here
capture the night captured here
yeah this was important yeah cuz you
know if you don't do this he somehow
puts the knight on the tree he's gonna
where he takes the pawn on c3 he's might
be back in the game you know takes now
threatening Bishop h6 and now it's it's
it's winning
so just what would be the easiest way to
finish him off here check to fix the
pawns when you're ahead you're never
afraid to trade if he doesn't trade we
win the pawn on a6 so he treat and now
he's only comfortably can occur if he
plays a5
so what are we gonna do stop it
and he designed here because my King
gets to e3 and eventually he will run
out of moves so just to show you I mean
I'm a whole piece so something like this
for example
well run out of moves and this he just
basically he'll you know and then I can
go here
it will be a Suk's among that's the
advantage of the bishop and the king
moves away and I take and this was a
good win it helped me finish the
tournament on a high note it was a good
win and it was an interesting game I
sacrificed a couple of pawns but I had
these two bishops and you know despite
him exchanging the Queen's I still had
you know I still had some good
initiative I really liked the move Queen
c5 because it puts pressure on the night
and if he captures my rook gets to a
strong square and then it was very
important to win this pawn put pressure
and the next maneuver because I'm still
down upon and you know he has before
coming here so so this was very
important moment Bishop g4 here and rook
d7
and a problem for him why can't he go
here why is this move losing
attacking the rook
and we take this now you cannot use the
square root be 8 and then again the
unfortunate back rank for him and now
this is hanging so I have to go here to
protect ok so that's the idea alright so
once again this was the groom felt
defense ok the 95 Bishop g5 line move
number 4 so you can look up some more
games it's very interesting line at some
point it was a very very popular very
very popular against Rome fall it's
still it's still sometimes you can find
top players who play this ok now I want
to show you a couple of tactical
positions ok ok white to play and win
this is a game of Audubon versus 3f ok
so spend a couple of minutes and then we
can discuss the idea so white is down an
entire look at the moment and black
would like to just cancel if he manages
to castle here we'll be in good shape
ok just just think for a few minutes we
have to calculate the entire line and
how you win the game don't just stop
when you win some much here because
you're ready you're already down the
rook
so you don't want to just stop when you
get some material you want to go a
little 2 moves deeper try to calculate
the entire setup the entire thing so
that requires the entire thing is 1 2 3
4 5 moves
okay we have a couple of people raising
their hands so let's give them a chance
now yes in the back Bishop d5 is a move
but then I can Castle and despite you
winning my knight I'm actually up a rock
so that's a little problem
huh
all alone castle yeah I mean it's not
there should be five we'll have to be
quicker yes ah dick
okay look t7 is a correct start
he takes okay he takes okay but remember
I told you go deeper right so King f8 so
I know you got here but did you
calculate further to find the entire win
remember who calculated the further
assisted sheesh subtle move here subtle
move here needed then Bishop yeah
that's an idea but what you got to do
first
so you're 95 comes with the force Queen
d5 rook c8 you have background issues
yes Queen b3 very subtle move attacking
this guy Bishop has to move and you got
the threat now you got this and you got
this
now the bishop is under attack the Queen
honest pawn honest seven and ninety five
is coming now if he goes here to try to
prove it's funny if he goes to here to
try to prevent ninety five you have
ninety five and Queen f7 mate if it was
Bishop d6 to cover the e5 square then
you have 95 he cannot protect them seven
and if he goes here
okay and now you take and you check and
same thing if it goes here you take
check and you go g3 then put the kink on
here got it so very important to
remember that okay and the other line is
if he goes to e 5 did you guys calculate
this move so for this we have to give a
check so King goes to a fade we
centralize the Queen attacking and now
he goes here threatening background
checkmate
so that needs to be addressed how g3 men
threatening Knight g5 and Queen f7 mate
ideas if Bishop e7 you have 95 so he
plays h6 age six I have 95 yes putting
pressure got it
when you get a comfortable position
alright let's do another one so we'll do
another similar black to play and win
how did he call Nakamura win this look
like relatively safe position for Wesley
so but no it's black to play yeah black
to play
okay then so night takes before that's
exactly what he missed Queen takes Queen
d1 checkmate beautiful so he took back
with the Queen and now Queen takes
threatening Queen d1 and and you want
quiet easily
you mean night here ninety-three maybe
Queen c2 now coming so yeah this is not
very good yeah before and you continue
the bishop is out of the game so you
continuously pushed upon sorry so here
you can even just check
they're coming so yeah so it looks like
the king is misplace so the king got
really misplaced okay you know and I
think maybe his King was on Jiwon he
kind of moved it over you know very
something like that okay all right great
job guys
we're gonna take a little break we have
another class coming up okay so this
class I'm gonna do some similar puzzles
which I think we're gonna be very useful
okay
[Music]